à mon avis christiane prend de la drogue
c'est une plaisanterie
elle est lunatique peu sérieuse
agressive et elle a également perdu du
poids attendez une minute christiane est
une adolescente
il n'empêche qu'elle a changé gelé noté
moi si
je connais ma fille
comment je vais faire pour trouver une
bonne lumière intime à moitié chauve chu
voir et qui les prêtres avec lui tu as
juste admettre à poil sommes pas besoin
de plus et de fil de la thur
[Musique]
c'est les princesses mais jeter raconter
ce qu'il avait fait
oui mais il a dit que c'est un
malentendu faudrait peut-être que tu
arrêtes d'être aussi susceptible
[Musique]
et
louise va t'accompagner dans une
clinique de ma tu as besoin de te faire
aider par des spécialistes
[Musique]
j'aime me retrouver tout seul et si le
duo qu'est ce que cette famille à quoi
dray un fixe pour moi de l'hérault
quelques chiffres
je me débrouille pour qu'on soit jeune
et recycle ses tarifs de par le trottoir
toi aussi
non celle en grèce jamais de la vie
des noms des noms se fait 1000 marques
de leurs
noms cela gagne notre héros si tu veux
java
ok g aussi tu te rend clairement
j'ai pas envie de faire ça mais j'ai
tellement envie de le faire
[Musique]
comment tu veux qu'on t'appelle
christiane christiane f